[Музика]
добре, хлопці, тож ласкаво просимо назад і давайте
сьогодні розважимося англійською, тому ми продовжуємо
говорити про Сполучене Королівство
Великої Британії, давайте заглибимося в цю
країну сьогодні, ми збираємося обговорити
політичну систему Сполученого
Королівства  Великобританія та Північна Ірландія,
але, звичайно, перед цим вам знадобиться
новий словниковий запас, тому подивіться,
завдання майже те саме, що ви повинні
зіставити словниковий запас із визначеннями,
і я прошу вас додати ще вісім слів до
вашого Quizlet, щоб перше слово  це
вибори, потім приходить уряд
політик прем'єр-міністр вони
виходять політичною партією більшість і
апатія, ви бачите, ви знаєте більшість цих
слів, тому що вони інтернаціональні, і
вони звучать майже однаково нашою
мовою, тому подивіться місце
група людей, які офіційно контролюють
країну, яку б ви вибрали, і
це уряд, який вони контролюють країну,
вони керують країною, або вони керують
країною, уряд потім спільно
член уряду чи іншої політичної
партії як ми називаємо цих людей, які
є членами уряду чи
всіх політичних партій, і ми називаємо їх
політиками політиком
майже такими ж словами українською
окей наступний лідер
уряду та  це прем'єр-міністр
знову майже така сама вимова
українською і наступне слово поведінка,
яке не виявляє інтересу до чогось,
а слово апатія, коли тобі не
цікаво і ти нічого не хочеш робити,
ти відчуваєш апатію добре наступне
слово коли  люди голосують, щоб вибрати людей, які
б представляли їх на політичних посадах, тому
цей процес називається виборами, ми
маємо вибори кожні чотири-п’ять років,
і це процес, коли ми йдемо і
голосуємо добре наступне число
людей, які голосують на виборах або
відвідати захід
це означає кількість людей, які прийшли
на подію або вибори, і
є інші люди, які підраховують тих, хто
прийшов на подію, і це називається
чергою  але вони виявляють кількість
людей, які приходять на вибори чи
подію, добре наступна
організація людей зі схожими політичними переконаннями
та ідеями, якщо хтось поділяє мої переконання
чи ідеї, ми можемо організувати політичну
партію добре, хлопці, ви готові  виконаємо
наступне завдання з читання, і давайте зробимо його
так, як ми маємо це робити під час наших ЗНО,
якби я був на ЗНО
спочатку, я б подивився на завдання,
і тут ми виконали повне
перед читанням тексту Я  я б робив
прогнози, я б переглядав усі
речення, які у мене є, і я б думав, що
я знаю про ці проблеми, чи можу я здогадатися,
тоді я буду дуже уважним,
читаючи текст, і я буду шукати
безпосередньо потрібну інформацію,
тому давайте подивимося  через речення
є лише дві політичні партії
у Великобританії, хм, я не знаю, що мій прогноз полягає в
тому, що це твердження є правдою, тому в
тексті я розглядатиму
кількість політичних партій, яка
потрібна політичній партії  загальна
більшість для формування уряду хм, можливо,
так, і моє минуле говорить мені, що,
ймовірно, це твердження відповідає дійсності, тому
номер три коаліційний уряд
складається з двох партій, які поділяють владу
коаліційний уряд українською мовою, ми
маємо майже те саме слово коаліція, тому
дві партії поділяють  power чи пам'ятаєте ви
дієслово share okay це означає
розділити владу між двома партіями,
тоді вам має бути 17 років або більше, щоб
проголосувати на загальних виборах у Великобританії
добре я знаю про вибори в Україні,
і я знаю, що вони мають бути  старше 18 років,
щоб мати можливість голосувати, тож давайте подивимося, чи це
правда для Великобританії чи ні, тоді приходить
менше половини людей віком від 18 до 24 років, які
проголосували на виборах 2015 року, подивіться
дуже гарно обійміться іноді у своїх
запитаннях у завданнях  можуть бути
підказки щодо інших питань, подивіться
тут, там написано для підлітків від 18 до 24 років, тож це
не підказка,
це питання може бути так, тоді
у Великобританії кожні три роки, ммм, кожні три роки, тому  Мені
потрібно уважніше придивитися, як часто
у Сполученому Королівстві проходять вибори, а тепер
перегляньте ще раз усі
твердження, які ви повинні відзначити як істинні чи
невірні, і приготуйтеся до завдання читання
добре, хлопці, давайте прочитаємо лідерів та
партій прем’єр  Міністр є
серцем уряду у Великобританії, а королева
чи король є главою держави.
Британці голосують на виборах за
членів парламенту. У Великобританії
є багато політичних партій,
але велика трійка — це
Лейбористська партія.  ліва
партія Ліберальні демократи – головна центральна
партія, а Консерватори – головна
права партія, є також партії, що
представляють різні частини Великобританії,
такі як Шотландська національна партія та
Пліт Комрі в Уельсі.
мажоритарна
система голосування політична партія, яка
набрала найбільше голосів, перемагає на виборах
для політичної партії у Великобританії, щоб
сформувати уряд, їм потрібна загальна
більшість цього  означає, що правляча
партія повинна мати більше членів
парламенту, ніж усі інші партії
разом узяті, якщо партія-переможець
не має загальної більшості, тоді
існує коаліційний уряд підвішеного парламенту,
що часто трапляється у
випадку підвішеного парламенту.  одна
велика партія об'єднається з меншою
партією, щоб сформувати коаліцію, таким чином
вони виключають головну
опозицію і все ще мають владу, хоча
тепер вона розділена між двома
коаліційними партіями, молоді люди та
політика, усі громадяни Великобританії
віком від 18 років можуть голосувати  на загальних виборах
дехто вважає, що молодь у
Британії апатична і не піклується
про політику близько 43% підлітків у віці від 18 до
24 років проголосували на загальних виборах 2015
року загальна явка зазвичай становить
близько 65% населення на загальних
виборах  проводяться приблизно кожні
п’ять років, і все більше молодих людей
вирішить проголосувати на наступних виборах, нам
доведеться почекати і побачити, добре, тому ми читаємо
весь текст і  d тепер ми маємо вибрати
, правдиві чи неправдиві твердження,
тож ось перше твердження, що
у Великобританії є лише дві політичні партії, відповідно
до чого ви пам’ятаєте так, є
більше двох політичних партій, принаймні
три, і ще дві політичні партії з  одна
з дуже цікавою назвою, тож
подивіться на речення, що
у Великобританії є багато політичних партій, але велика
трійка - це Лейбористська партія, основна
ліва партія, Ліберальні демократи,
головна центральна партія, і
консерватори - головна права-  крило партії
добре, отже, у нас є три і ще
кілька незначних, добре, і твердження
невірне, воно позначено червоним, добре,
наступне політичній партії потрібна загальна
більшість, щоб сформувати уряд, тому це
твердження вірне, воно позначено зеленим
і  Доказове речення з тексту говорить
нам, що
для політичної партії у Великобританії, щоб
сформувати уряд, їй потрібна загальна
більшість. Тут ви можете побачити, що це
питання дуже легко, тому що в
тексті вони використовували майже  ту саму
структуру речення, тож це пряма
інформація, тут вони не використовують синоніми
або не кажуть, що те саме
в інший спосіб добре,
давайте рухатися далі, так що коаліційний
уряд складається з двох партій, які
поділяють владу, і це твердження  правда
знову позначено зеленим, а речення
в тексті говорить, що часто трапляється у
випадку підвішеного парламенту: одна
велика партія об'єднається з меншою
партією, щоб сформувати коаліцію тут у
завданні, яке ми маємо іншими словами, і це
сказано  коаліційний уряд складається
з двох партій, які розподіляють владу, і тут
вони використовують ці синоніми, тому об’єднуються
з меншою партією, щоб сформувати коаліцію,
тому іноді вам потрібно знати про
синоніми та шукати
синоніми в тексті.  один, вам має
бути 17 років або більше, щоб проголосувати на загальних
виборах у Великобританії, тому твердження є
помилковим, усі громадяни Великобританії
старше 18 років можуть писати на загальних виборах, і
знову вони використовували іншу
конструкцію sen  Після цього вони використали модальне дієслово
can and vote разом, а тут вони
використовують інше модальне дієслово have to be so again,
слідкуйте за синонімами наступний
менше половини людей віком від 18 до 24 років
проголосували на виборах 2015 року, тому
твердження є  правда
приблизно 43 відсотки людей віком від 18 до 24 років
проголосували на загальних виборах 2015 року, а
43 відсотки є синонімом до менш ніж
половини, означає 50%, а тут ми маємо
лише 43 відсотки, добре, отже, останні
є загальні вибори  кожні три
роки у Великобританії, це дуже легко, і
це неправда, тому що загальні вибори
проводяться приблизно кожні п'ять років,
знову ось синоніми, і
в питанні сказано, що є
загальні вибори, а тут загальні
вибори проводяться інші
структура речення, але це синоніми,
добре, так що давайте рухатися далі, і я хочу, щоб ви
трохи обговорили та поділилися зі мною
своїми ідеями, а ось питання, які
я хотів би вислухати вашу думку щодо
них, щоб ви могли знову надіслати мені повідомлення  або  ви можете
надіслати голосове повідомлення і мені дуже
цікаві ваші ідеї або і ви
цікавитеся політикою і чи хотіли б ви
бути політиком і які питання
які теми важливі в нашій країні
сьогодні дуже важливо
вислухати молодь  тому що ви ті,
хто буде жити в цій країні і хто
повинен буде будувати цю країну, і
останнє питання, як ви думаєте, всі
повинні голосувати, чи не повинно бути деяких
категорій людей, яким слід
дозволити голосувати, тому не соромтеся висловлювати
ваші ідеї, давайте поговоримо про
це і обговоримо ці питання
з однокласниками, однокласниками, батьками та
друзями, добре,
тож, можливо, ви вже знаєте, що
буде далі, британцям подобаються їхні
традиції, тож давайте дотримуємося наших
традицій і знову драма про п’яту годину
ми з чаєм хочемо розпочати нашу п’яту годину
драматичного чаю, перевіряючи ваші домашні завдання, щоб у
вас був довгий список речень, щоб
відкрити дужки, і я сподіваюся, що ви зробили їх
правильно,
тож ви б  подивіться на оренду, і
ось відповіді, тому щойно
почався дощ,
вона взяла свою парасольку, а потім він грав у
карти після того, як зробив домашнє завдання,
перш ніж вона подякувала мені, що вона взяла мій
подарунок, тому спочатку вона взяла
подарунок, а потім  вона подякувала йому, і
це дуже ввічливо,
ми побачили грабіжників після того, як вони
покинули групу,
тому спочатку грабіжники покинули банк,
а потім ми побачили їх, і він розчесав
волосся після того, як почистив зуби, тому
спочатку він почистив зуби першим
дія, а потім він розчісується, а потім
приходить до того, як ми вийшли ми взули
наші нові черевики так, тому спочатку взуйся,
а потім виходь, вони пішли купатися
після того, як дощ припинився, тож дочекайтеся,
поки дощ припиниться, а потім йдіть купатися
коли ми приїхали туди, церемонія
вже почалася, тому ми спізнилися на
церемонію, вони її вже почали,
тому ми повинні були зайти мовчки,
тоді батько номер 12
почав мити машину
матері, з'їхала, так що це значить  ns, що він
чекав, поки
мати вийде, а потім тільки він почав
мити свою машину, а потім, коли вона отримала
свою нову сукню, вона показала його
батькам, це дуже приємно, коли батьки
приймають ваш вибір, тому вона спочатку купила
його, а потім показала  потім номер 14
він впав з балкона після того, як
зняв їх перила, о, це сумно,
тому перше, що він зробив, він
зняв перила, а потім він упав
з балкона, а останнє він
з'їв пиріг після того, як він  запитав, тому спочатку
він запитав добре, хлопці, це було ваше домашнє
завдання, а тепер я хочу, щоб ви об’єднали свої
знання про три часи, і давайте подивимося, що
ми отримали минуле simple past continuous
і past perfect
всі три часи в одному ще раз,
будь ласка, згадайте past simple a  окрема
дія в минулому і слова, які
показують вам, що це минуле просте,
зазвичай втрачено або вчора, потім минуле
безперервна довга дія в минулому, і
іноді воно може бути перервано
минулим простим і останнім  є минулого
досконалого, тому минулий досконалий, коли ми маємо
дві дії в минулому, і одна відбулася
перед іншою дією знову в
минулому, тому утворення past simple є
другою формою дієслова, якщо він правильний
на кінці IDI, якщо він неправильний,
зверніться до  таблиця якщо ви не знаєте, то
минуле тривало було слово плюс ing форма
збиралася читали, а минуле досконалий
мав плюс третя форма знову, якщо ви
не знаєте,
розв’яжіть таблицю неправильних дієслів або
це ідентифікатор закінчення для правильних дієслів  тож
давайте подивимося на цю тривалішу
ситуацію, коли вони підсовують, злодії
проникають і крадуть їхні картини, дуже
погана ситуація, то що ми маємо тут, ми
маємо тут довшу дію, і це
перша, а потім у нас є дві дії,
які перервані  довше подумайте
трохи, а потім я покажу вам відповідь
добре, тож ось відповідь, коли
вони спали, злодії увірвалися та вкрали
їхні картини добре, чи ви зробили це
правильно, я сподіваюся, що ви зробили, тож перейдемо
до наступного  після того, як він відремонтував свій велосипед, він
під'їхав до бабусі та дідуся, чи міг би він
їздити на зламаному велосипеді. Ні,
то тут у нас є дві дії, одна
за одною, тож яка з них
перша, звичайно, йому довелося відремонтувати
велосипед, тому Райт відремонтував свій  велосипед,
а потім він поїхав до бабусі й дідуся
перевірити місце пробігу після того, як він
відремонтував свій велосипед, він поїхав до
бабусі й дідуся ще раз добре, перш ніж
вона пообідала, вона знову працює в саду, у
нас є дві дії та те, що
трапилося раніше  Отже, що
сталося спочатку, вона попрацювала в саду
, це перша дія, а що
сталося потім,
вона повечеряла, подумай, відкрий дужку,
а потім перевір відповідь,
добре, ось,
перед тим, як вона повечеряла, вона працювала
в саду,
добре, ще раз я бачу його  вчора
перед кінотеатром так дуже легко, що ви
потрапили сюди вчора, і якщо це було вчора
, це, безумовно, минуло просто, тому вам
потрібно поставити це C у другу форму
, і це я бачив його вчора
перед  кіно добре, наступний,
коли вони слухають музику, вони чують
гучний шум, тому вони
слухали, коли почули гучний
шум, тому відкрийте дужку
і перевірте, будь ласка, відповідь, яку ви отримали
, коли вони слухали  під музику
вони почули гучний шум цей гучний шум
перервав довшу дію добре,
тоді він не відвідає мене, перш ніж він прилетів до
Греції, добре, тут ми знову маємо цю підказку,
якщо у нас є дві дії,
і ми отримали це раніше, це означає, що
ми маємо поставити одне в минуле досконале,
тому яка дія відбулася спочатку,
людина не прийшла до мене в гості, а
потім прилетіла до Греції, тому ми повинні поставити цю
дію до минулого досконалого і відкрити
дужку, і ви побачите  відповідає добре,
він не відвідував мене до того, як прилетів до
Греції, звичайно, ви можете використовувати цю коротку
форму, наприклад, не добре, наступна моя
сестра тут гучний крик ззовні
та кинутися назовні моя сестра щось почула
і зробила, тож це двоє
дії, що відбуваються в а  гребіть, як у
казці, як у казці, то що б ви
вибрали, відкрийте, і тоді ви побачите
правильну відповідь, щоб перевірити ваше передбачення,
добре, тому моя сестра почула гучний крик
ззовні та вибігла добре, хлопці, так що ви
чудово попрацювали сьогодні і  ми
висвітлювали дуже важливу і складну тему
політичної системи Сполученого
Королівства Великобританії. Я попросив вас обговорити
кілька питань з вашими батьками,
вашими однокласниками або зі мною, але перед тим, як
виконувати це дуже серйозне завдання, я хочу,
щоб ви повеселилися,
і ви  будь ласка, перейдіть за цим посиланням і
розв’яжіть кросворд онлайн, ви можете
зробити це в будь-який час, і не
соромтеся запитати підказки, там будуть деякі
підказки, і просто отримуйте задоволення. Вивчаючи англійську
англійську мову, це не тільки граматика або
читання величезного тексту, а також  про якусь забаву,
і я хочу нагадати вам, щоб обговорювати
ці питання не знову я хотів би
послухати ваші відповіді, так що знову ви
цікавитесь політикою, чи хотіли б ви
бути політиком, які питання
важливі  tant for Ukraine, і ви думаєте, що
всі мають голосувати, тому зв’яжіться зі мною та
насолоджуйтеся вивченням англійської, залишайтеся з нами,
побачимось наступного разу
[Музика]